I'm very dexterous with my toes I could
braid someone's hair with my toes over
again they're like oh yeah really yeah I
reckon I could okay play a piano
whatever I mean so I could pick a lock
no problem
James is like don't worry we'll cut in
and do like a we'll cut into this don't
worry about it and I was like no I
reckon like I reckon I got it actually
and
I remember we were gonna have to for
like a uh you know to cut in clothes
we're gonna have to use someone else
because I had to get to another set but
our editor actually edited Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood and he was like those
aren't Margot Robbie's feet I have seen
Margaret obviously
believe me I'm on Twitter I know people
want to see your feet I don't know where
these people come from but do we get to
see Margo's feet I'm like that's what
you're thinking about we've got
we've got buildings fall over we've got
Idris Elba John Cena Margot Robbie all
these great people but those are the
stars